Namah says writing in diverse teams may
come with creative ideas alongside when
you need quick consensus among members
with diverse backgrounds and culture how
do we achieve it so that the firm moves
forward ahead is one team that's great
question so a NamUs I think I'll go to
this um language is pretty important to
me so I think it's really good in the
more diversity you have you tend to find
different cultures come together
something you need a common language
around how do we serve and number one
always you know use phrases like we've
got to put ourselves in the shoes of the
customer what does a customer need so
even in meetings I sometimes keep an
empty chair for the customer and say
well what would the customer what would
the customer want us to do here and then
I'd always encourage you have a culture
where you get facts and data in the room
if anybody's got a point of view they
should say I think as a leader you want
to encourage the people who don't speak
often because sometimes they're the
brightest people in the room but they
might feel intimidated so and then when
you've got that you frame what is it
we're trying to achieve here what is the
right answer for the customer how do we
get to market or whatever the the
problem of the day is and then you get
agreement around what the decision is
and then you know phrase I use
internalized you know if you make a
decision and you take no accountability
no action and no timeline and no outcome
of what that decision is then you know
if you leave the scene of that decision
then consider that there's no decision
ever made because a decision without an
outcome or an action is you know a loser
nation it never happens so I think a
great culture a great culture is where
you have the discussion you get the
facts and the data and you put yourself
the shoes of the customers say how we
make a difference here you make the
decision you lock that down get
everybody crystal clear about what their
accountabilities and who's who's going
to be responsible for delivering that to
the team and it could be a team effort
and then
then you say right what a successful all
right what's the outcome what are we
going to have it 30 days 10 days 5 days
and say let's get back together the next
week we have a coffee and just make sure
we did what we set do it so I think it
is a leader you can really be a bit of a
hustler
but and also I think where this is
important you've got to be authentic
again with yourself you've got to have
you hold yourself to account so if you
commit to things for the team you've got
a deliverance you and you've got a you
know walk the talk and set the tone for
the company you build it I like that
empty seats to the cusp I've never heard
that I've consumed a lot of content I've
never heard anybody do that have an
empty seat and imagine the customers
there that's cool I mean I might use
that I think two things I agree Stephen
I think the mission is the unifying goal
like why are we doing this what if you
have clarity on why you're here that
makes it so much easier to gather around
and move forward I think - in terms of
cultural diversity a lot of the work can
be done in advance as well ideally you
know if you're over communicating and
I'm really trying to understand each
other then you already have a sense of
how to work together before you come to
the table to make this really important
decision and not have to figure that out
on the spot even you know if you look at
Stephen he let off with a quote from
Justin Trudeau who is the Canadian Prime
Minister and every time we do something
I'm Canadian so there's always some
Canadian content in there I always
appreciate that right like Stephens done
his homework he's always prepared I'm
sure when he's going to France he has
some French thing that he's going to be
sharing and that means a lot you know to
the people that you're talking to you
that you taking the time to understand
their culture to understand them a
little bit more so that when you do get
together you have that important
decision to make it makes it easier to
move forward the same path so the
alignment around the goal and also the
prep work the ground work the awareness
to understand them prior to having to
make that decision I think is really
important
you